Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism,
living tissue over meadow.
This podcast is brought to you by four sigmatic.
I reached out to these Finnish folks,
young entrepreneurs,
very talented.
After a acrobat introduced me to one of their products,
which is mushroom coffee.
This specific one includes Chaga and lion's mane and it knocked my socks off.
I highly recommend if you try it,
you start with half packet.
It's very strong and lights you up like a Christmas tree in the best way
possible.
People are always asking me what I use for cognitive enhancement and for right
now this is the answer.
I try to force this on all of my house guests.
It is a hell of a thing.
If I have employees or people come over who are working on projects with me,
I always try to feed it to them because I'm going to get the limitless effect
and get a lot more out of them.
The first time I mentioned this product and four sigmatic on the podcast,
their products sold out in less than a week,
so you may want to check them out soon.
If you're listening to this and the coffee tastes like coffee,
it takes just seconds to prepare with hot water.
And oddly enough only includes 40 milligrams of caffeine,
so it has less than half of what you'd get in a regular cup of coffee.
I don't get any jitters,
acid reflux or any stomach burn,
any of that.
It's very unusual and very,
very cool.
So if you don't like caffeine,
they also offer very strong but caffeine free mushroom elixirs,
which I will sometimes have in the evening.
I find Chaga specifically to be very,
very grounding and earthy.
So that is another option.
And I have a cupboard full of their products,
uh,
at the moment,
which is right around the corner of my kitchen.
You can try something,
you can try a sample pack,
which is great.
Also right now by going to foursigmatic.com forward slash Tim that's
foursigmatic,
F,
O,
U R S,
I g,
m a t I c.com forward slash Tim and use the Code Tim Tim to get 20% off of your
first order and they're not that expensive.
Anyway,
if you are in the experimental mindset,
I do not think you'll be disappointed,
so try them out.
This episode is brought to you by audible,
which I've used for many,
many years.
I absolutely love audio books in there.
One of my favorite ways to pass the time when I travel,
I'm on the road all the time in audible allows me to consume many more books
than I possibly could otherwise I have to audio books to recommend right off the
bat.
The first is perhaps my favorite audio book of all time and it's the only audio
book I've wanted to listen to twice in a row.
The graveyard book by Neil Gaiman.
It's amazing and you will thank me.
There are a few different versions.
I like the version that Neil narrates himself,
one of the most soothing voices of all time.
The second book is vagabonding by Rolf Potts,
p o t t,
s which had a huge impact on my life and formed the basis for a lot of what
would later become the four hour workweek,
so go to audible.com forward slash Tim and you can choose one of these two books
or any of many,
many other options that could be books,
magazines,
and much more as a listener of the Tim Ferriss show,
you can also access a free 30 day trial.
Just go to audible.com forward slash Tim you can't make more time,
but you can make the most of it.
So turn your travel or your commute into something more with a free trial at
audible.
Go to audible.com forward slash Tim to start now and get your free 30 day trial.
Little boys and girls.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss show.
I'm sitting in a cabin surrounded by snow and it is still my job every episode
to deconstruct world class performers of all different types from entertainment,
military,
chess to Jujitsu,
you name it.
I've tried to interview the best of the best in that world and in this
particular episode we are going to talk about anti aging.
What does that mean?
Well,
there's a lot of hogwash 11 don since out there,
but there were a few people who really stand out as particularly interesting
because they walk the talk.
Doctor Arthur Devini is nearly 80 years old and totally ripped.
I just spent a bunch of time with him and better known as Art Devani and you
should check them out on Facebook,
facebook.com forward slash art dot devane e.
He was signed as a professional baseball player in his youth and later earned
his phd in economics at Ucla.
He is most famous for his evolutionary fitness.
That's the term you would use.
Approach to training and Diet and our conversation focuses a lot on the
subtleties and details of that.
During his time at Ucla,
art did many things including creating mathematical and statistical models to
precisely described the motion picture.
Market.
Art is now professor emeritus of economics of the University of California at
Irvine is a member of their claimed institute for Mathematical Behavioral
Sciences.
So this guy is very analytical.
He's very mathematical and very,
very logical,
and that is the water on the kettle.
But I'm going to power through it because I'm going to have tea,
but it's going to be after this intro is recorded,
a lifelong student of metabolism and fitness.
Art has lived as a Paleo athlete for more than 30 years and is considered a
patriarch of the Paleo movement right up there with Loren Cordain.
He believes there's no such thing as healthy aging and that we can intervene to
protect against the aging process.
And in this episode we talk about his daily schedule workout routines,
Nassim Taleb,
why he never gets sick.
That is why art and ever get sick and really dig into the details of a
fascinating man.
There's also one point where I doubt myself,
which happens fairly often,
and I mentioned myotonic reflex.
Then I renege and say,
I don't know what I'm talking about.
So just to explain what I meant by that.
Here's the definition.
The stretch reflex,
also known as myotonic reflex.
This is from Wikipedia is a muscle contraction and response to stretching within
the muscle.
It is a motto synaptic reflex,
which provides automatic regulation of skeletal muscle life.
When a muscle lengthens the muscle spindles stretched and it's nerve activity
increases.
That sounds like Gobbledygook to a lot of you,
but that is why I said myotonic reflex.
It's,
it's related to doing negative only or negative dominant workouts,
which arc arc arc subscribes to.
All right,
so that you have it.
There's a lot of a dense stuff in here.
We get into the weeds,
which you guys love,
but if you're having trouble grasping something and it's getting very dense,
just hold on and listen for a few more minutes and we'll get back into more
familiar territory.
We talked about everything from ice ages to economics to the philosophies of
intermittent everything.
We talk about the extreme events and the economics thereof.
It's a fascinating conversation.
At least it was for me.
So without further a do,
as I always say,
I'm going to go get my tea now.
Please enjoy this conversation with art.
Defaming
art.
Welcome to the show.
Happy to be here.
Tim,
I am thrilled to meet you.
I've heard so much about you for many people,
including our mutual friend,
Navarro,
Arabica,
and we're sitting here for those people listening at my undisclosed mountain
location.
And art was kind enough to meet me here.
And here we are at the kitchen table and I thought we would just start with how
you connected with novel because I don't know the story.
I started with my blog.
He,
he got in touch with me and uh,
I decided to give a seminar in Las Vegas covering sort of the elements of my
approach and he and his brother Kamala gendered,
along rich with uh,
John Daron.
Sure.
And uh,
Richard Nikolay and then a whole bunch of other people who've gone on to famous,
unfortunate in the Paleo world.
And you've kept in,
in contact with neval or at least he is certainly very familiar with,
with the blog.
If we rewind the clock a little bit,
how did you go?
Well actually I'll take a step back.
I was going to ask you how you went from economics to the evolutionary approach
to everything.
Uh,
but before I go there,
how did you get to economics?
Oh yeah.
Well,
I loved economics.
Uh,
it's a study of a decentralized mechanisms and organizations and spontaneous
order.
I got into it because a,
I took an undergraduate class and comparative economic systems at Ucla
and I had a professor who was just profoundly inspiring in that class.
George Murphy give him credit.
He May,
he may just claim my credit,
but he,
uh,
he was so eloquent in talking about a high oak and uh,
Oh God,
Enrico Baroni and a whole bunch of other people who wrestled with central
planning.
It's a time when central planning was sweeping Europe and as being promoted,
even in the United States,
the,
the progressive movement at that time,
if they felt this centralized control,
scientific management top down hierarchical control would be the sensible way to
do.
In fact,
I wrote a book about the inland waterways that criticize that approach.
And talked about how they actually messed up the flood plains and they thought
there was a hundred year flood plain,
but floods don't have means statistics,
they don't converge.
They diverge.
So the variants keeps growing with every new flood.
What does that,
for people who don't have any familiar with a familiarity with economics,
what does that,
what does that mean?
If you could maybe elaborate on that.
Well,
the variance of course is a merit measure of the variation in the series and the
series if it hasn't been,
you know,
most people think in terms of normal distributions that has central tendencies
and that the main and variation are well described by those two parameters.
Not True.
The damage that's done by the worst rainstorm in a decade does 40% of all the
damage that that rainstorms do in that decade.
This is,
it's a,
it's an extreme event dominated series.
Just like the movies and just like your life,
people fail to realize you,
you know,
you don't get anywhere from the drip,
drip,
drip of the incremental,
you get there from some big event that changes your life.
Like your book probably changed your life.
I don't know what changed my life.
Lots of things out.
Um,
but those are the moments that are the power moments in your life.
And in fact,
the whole notion of normal,
it doesn't apply to a person's life.
You know,
you don't get anywhere by incrementing in small increments is the extreme event
and you seize it and you're poised,
you remained poise.
You can respond to that kind of significant event.
For example,
there's this notion of algorithmic compressability,
which is a computer science term that applies to the ability to reduce your life
to an algorithm.
Can't do it,
can't do it if the novelty in your life is constantly progressing and you should
welcome the variants,
seize the opportunities.
Um,
that was,
that's the way I,
I think of life fitness,
the Zen of evolutionary fitness.
That's Ah,
that's how life works out.
So we're going to spend the majority,
I think of our conversation on evolutionary fitness and I have so many questions
for you,
but I want to start with an area I know even less about,
which is Hollywood.
So W,
w,
w what are some of the erroneous beliefs,
uh,
or,
that you,
that you've found in Hollywood or insights that,
that,
uh,
you've written about and studied?
Well,
you know,
it's an industry that nobody understands.
Nobody has really written everything very sensible about the industry.
Their Supreme Court,
for example,
divorced the studios from the theaters.
And,
uh,
Justice Douglas was a guy who wrote the decision,
the famous paramount antitrust decrees.
It treated the industry as a monopoly because they looked at market shares,
which if you measure it a particular point in time,
parametal have so many dollars of the total revenue of the industry.
Universal,
we have so many.
And,
and on down the line problem is it changes every week.
So if you use a something like a Herfindahl index or a measure of concentration,
it's constantly varying.
In fact,
it has no mean,
it's the second moment of,
excuse me,
just a second,
is the variance of the distribution of market shares,
the Herfindahl Index.
It is,
and it's infinite.
It doesn't exist.
Amalinh Volvo wrote about this.
So did,
uh,
Oh,
who's he and the guy who did did fractals
anyway,
it doesn't matter who the,
Oh,
is it?
Middleborough.
Yeah.
Middleborough he,
he coined the word fractal.
And because it's a,
it's a situation where the variation is so extreme that the distribution itself
doesn't have the normal kinds of lifts of limits.
It's a so called wild distribution as nothing to lab calls him if he's wild.
Distributions don't have finite moments necessarily.
The meaning variants may not exist as such as an invalid.
A example.
And that's true also in the movies,
it turned out that the movies has such a wild distribution that even the mean
doesn't exist.
So if you talk about the average gross,
you're talking about no movie that ever made that
they all reminds me of a,
there's a some type of joke that was meant to illustrate the flaw in how people
miss apply arithmetic green mean.
And so,
you know,
Bill Gates walks into a bar and suddenly the average net worth is $50 million or
something like that.
Bill Gates walks into a bar and everybody's a millionaire on average.
Yeah,
exactly.
So,
yeah,
it's a,
does this make movies impossible to predict
or plan for?
How would you build that in?
If you ran a studio,
how would that inform,
uh,
what you've learned?
How would that inform decisions that you make?
Well,
you,
you've got to have a story and characters,
the audience will love,
as you remember Kelly Query,
she invited me to come speak to this screen,
accurate,
the screenwriter's guild.
And she said,
you make a movie by you make the audience,
love the characters and then you tortured
torture the characters.
Yeah.
And would be visa vi the characters,
the audience torture the characters,
right?
So the idea is that you a great script or great story,
memorable characters,
then the rest is up to the audience.
It may or may not work.
I'm an actor,
has the same kind of arrogance in his career grosses as does the industry in
general so that an accurate way or make one movie and that movie will earn 40%
of the actor's career revenues.
Same thing with directors.
If you,
if you did all the regressions in the world is a statistical technique for
trying to predict what a movie's going to make.
You would find out that a handful of actors have any significance.
And there's sort of Luke's anyway,
like Val Kilmer Kilmore Kilmore came up in that,
in the regression equations he's going now.
I mean it's,
it's not that
the past doesn't predict the future's really the way to look at it and there's
no algorithm to determine how a movie's going to gross genre is somewhat
helpful,
but only because people look as genre.
Genre is not a category is something that people put.
It's a box.
People put put movies in.
You really want to know how much a movie is going to make.
You have to um,
look at how many theaters of the,
open it on.
It's the cereal box effect.
If you go into grocery store and we'd eat,
gets all the shelf space,
except for food a few inches,
it's going to have the highest gross.
It might disappear very quickly though because of a big opening is a,
is a dangerous strategy.
It tends to give you a dominant revenues in the early weeks.
And if people follow the revenues as a means of making a decision,
how to go,
which movie to go to,
that would tend to propel an,
an uh,
a dynamic where you would have an expansive gross problem is you also have word
of mouth and reviews.
So it's,
it's a mixture of public and private information,
private information being when your friends tell you about it,
public information being,
reading the box office scores,
you put those two together and you just have an enormously complicated dynamics.
You can't tell how it's going to do
asthma.
As a matter of fact,
if,
if you don't get the grosses and you can have 4,000 theaters committed their
screens to your movie,
you may have to allow them to double bill in the second week.
That is add another feature to it.
Oh,
I see.
If you see a movie that stubble building by the third week,
it's a stinker.
So,
and uh,
yeah,
I would,
I would imagine it's similar to books too.
I mean,
I suppose in any hits driven business,
there are some people who try to front load with distribution,
so they have this huge initial upfront cost in the hopes that it will make the
list somewhere at the top and then become a as a self fulfilling cycle of sorts
where people use it as a shop
kind of thing and actually a lot of authors or go out and buy lots of copies of
your book.
Oh yeah,
I know.
I know of people who've bought,
you know,
I remember I visited,
I shall not name names,
but I went to the the office,
the headquarters of a CEO who had recently published his own book,
or I should say had his book published,
which he did not.
Right,
and there were tens of thousands of copies lighting the wall.
It was just outrageous.
He could have built an entire structure out of these books.
The public has to,
they,
they're smart.
They've learned that if you just look at the sales itself,
that's what a lot of other people are doing.
But it could be that they're,
they're manipulating the sales as a way of signaling to you that it's a great
book.
So you,
you look at reviews and you see what the author's done before it might work if
you're Tom Hanks in the movie.
But then again it could be,
he said he has huge variance in his gross is also,
he's not a sure thing.
What a star will do is it will raised the least revenue.
Okay.
A film minor.
I see.
It raises the Ma the,
the,
the minimum revenue because it gets it out on a fair number of screens and some
people will come,
but then word of mouth starts to take over and it can,
it can tank and no time.
So you developed these,
these mental models,
this analytical,
these analytical frameworks.
How did fitness and diet enter the scene for you and,
or how,
how did,
how did that,
how did you start focusing on that?
It really bang began the other way around.
I always wanted to be fit and strong.
Yeah.
And have a beautiful body and you know,
a healthy looking skin and so forth.
And it's just like people liking me and looking at me.
So ego helps a lot
in this game.
Yeah.
But I also was interested in,
in fitness and eating well most of my life.
However that meant that blended with that plus my interest in athletics and I
wanted to be a pro baseball player,
I site let me down.
So those that,
that mixture led me to appreciate the hunter gatherer kind of lifestyle that
that is.
If you,
if you view uncertainty in the world the way I do,
and you realize that we came through a narrow bottleneck,
only 2,500 or so humans made it through the Toba,
the Post Toba,
volcanic eruption,
a volcanic winter.
There was a lowest temperature in the,
in the last 20,000 years it was was post Toba.
And so we came through a bottleneck like that.
You realize that we have to be extremely hardy,
very robust.
You had to be poised.
The brain is there in order to adapt to the climate variations that the humans
went through.
There were,
there were 20,000 years of extreme climate variation and a good brain is a good
way to gift gift through that sort of thing.
You can imagine God's designers,
human designers saying,
well,
we've got a new kind of,
we got a new model now it's different from the archaic model in the sense it has
a very large brain.
It's smart as hell.
This kind of fat and slow
and God just says,
well,
let's see if it gets through.
The Ice Age is a high of 20,000 years of ice ages plans ahead of it and that's
what happened.
The archaic form didn't last and they all,
all the other closely related forms of,
uh,
of human beings disappeared.
If his time in the end,
Athol,
the Homo heidelbergensis and a whole host of other,
even home,
my rectus was still around early on in this period,
2000,
200,000 years ago.
So they all disappeared and they all disappeared because you didn't have the
adaptive behavior that uh,
that modern human sound,
that rain was the survival instrument.
That means that,
uh,
we're here.
We have a great brain simply because it's a way of adapting to the challenges
that the world presents to us and you couldn't have the brain that we have
unless you had a body as well.
The brain body,
his brain muscle cell signaling is dominates most of my thinking.
Uh,
so a fit in approach to fitness,
it will think of the sea squirt.
I'll admit I don't know much about sea squirts and sea squirts,
a little polyp that lives in the sea and it floats around,
finds a location,
latches onto that Barca lounger and eats a sprain,
eats its own brand,
each its own brain because it's found his place.
It no longer needs to navigate that world and the brain is dispensable and every
bit of protein and substrate that's the animal can get ahold of if
of course it's going to eat.
So at that point,
the sea squirt consumes a sprain.
A lot of people do that too.
Don't think it's going to say,
I think a lot of that's happening right now.
Yeah,
yeah.
Settling into a couch,
you lose your,
you lose your muscle,
your brain begins to degenerate.
Because it's not giving the signals at the muscles muscles release all kinds of
so called myokines now that had been discovered.
And it also a remote signal from the muscle can cause your brain to improve its
cell quality to maintain neurons.
One thing you could do is to contract muscles and you'll find you improve what's
called proteostasis in,
in,
in the neurons.
Proteostasis is maintaining the cellular quality,
not having misfolded proteins,
misshapen proteins,
rock Haina pro changing your,
is that related to uh,
like a brain drive neurotrophic factor or things like that?
Or is it adults mechanism?
It also does that with see neurotropic factors,
typically growth type factors that rescue,
uh,
a stressed cell.
And that does happen.
But the other part of it is that you need to alter insulin signaling so that
you're actually
bring on the defensive pathways in that neuron as opposed to the growth,
right?
The growth factors and the signal a seat way so that we're bringing on the facts
show in search tunes and other factors in there in the neuron.
So that kind of signaling,
and if you,
if you affect proteostasis in the brain,
the brain then can send neurosignals to affect proteostasis in remote tish
tissues.
Now we're into this notion of remote cetainly or signaling at a distance,
which is systemic signaling.
Economists love that kind of a,
and you know,
the kind of model that adaptive kind of decentralized behavior and what,
uh,
what types of,
if,
if we're looking at,
for instance,
I was listening to one of your presentations and one of the,
on one of the slides I just wrote down two lines and it was,
it reads,
eating is not programmed.
It is the result of the failure of a renewal program.
Right.
And so I would love to hear you a elaborate on that maybe a little bit and then
be,
uh,
follow that through with the,
the implications in terms of behaviors that might help or diet,
anything that might help to,
uh,
bolster that renewal system.
Man.
Well,
you know,
aging is a really,
um,
a puzzle.
I only started studying it a few years ago and I figured,
well,
I'm an expert because I'm experienced.
I was about 78 years old when I started looking at aging.
And as I thought it really is a lot simpler than people who are making it out to
be.
It is not programmed.
There are,
there's no,
no aging genes have been discovered.
The only just changed that had been discovered to have any bearing on aging or
defensive pathways.
Foxo sir.
Two wins.
Proteostasis a host of other defensive immunity,
stem cell proliferation there four or five pathways that are involved in aging
and in the main,
they are regenerative or defensive pathways like,
like immunity,
the immune pathways crossover with your,
uh,
cell maintenance.
Defensive Pathways.
For example,
a toffee is used in both processes.
That's off as you being the,
the consumption of self tissues of own tissues,
faith Faigy being eating and being you,
your own tissues.
So tough a topic you use both an element of the immune system.
It's also an element of keeping the stem cells alive and healthy because they're
living on its Alpha g and when they,
when they need to proliferate and come out and heal wounds,
your tissues,
they go through a burst of photographer cheating and then they transition into,
into oxidative phospho they use are actually for pathways.
After that,
Varian,
they're being defended by a topic cheese,
so that,
that the mitochondria don't damage the stem cells.
They have to live in a low oxygen niche,
but they're very similar to a very primitive form of cell.
Uh,
they live on basically,
um,
glycolysis.
And there was all life lived at one time and your fast twitch muscle fibers also
used the most primitive kind of
energy sources for,
for movement.
So the defensive pathways or that really the key to it all in,
and the pier at the poet's Novis,
the legend of [inaudible] is a legend of the Greek God of Aurora was he was a
row or rowers boyfriend.
And Zeus didn't like it.
So of Aurora pleaded with him,
with Zeus not to kill him.
So Zeus in his clever way said,
well,
okay,
you're going to live forever.
But he didn't,
he forgot to say,
I'm not going to let you age.
So to thoroughness wastes away for eternity as a,
as a cruel punishment,
but it's a correct description of what the aging process is.
So loss of cell function,
loss of cell integrity,
a loss of the ability of stem to renew
tissues.
So aging basically is simply damage.
What are some of the interventions that a,
that you find most interesting?
At this point,
I eat only twice a day.
So I log,
I want long intervals between meals.
I want low insulin signaling so that I bring on the defensive and repair
pathways.
I want to be conscious of maintaining my stem cells.
How do you maintain your stem cells?
Well,
first of all,
you don't have too much mitochondria with density down in your stem cells.
So I,
yeah,
I really want to talk about this.
Mitochondrial density is all the rage.
All right.
I mean,
it seems to be all the rage,
isn't it?
Like they're innocent little batteries that just sacrifice and produce energy
for it.
You remember they have their own DNA,
so mitochondria density.
It has to be very low in the stem cell niches.
Moreover,
that mitochondrial activity level,
for example,
humans,
people don't know this.
Humans had the lowest mitochondria density of any mammal.
Really?
Yes,
and they also have low,
low reactive type of Mitochondria.
The l three we all came off out of the l three mitochondrial appetite that left
Africa number mitochondrial eve accrued about how to 6,000 38,000 years ago.
By that time it's humans were huddled on the seashore,
South Africa trying to survive the,
the temperature was so cold and so much ice was locked up moisture that the
Sahara expanded in scope and became very arid.
So after,
after Toba,
a volcanic eruption of the largest volcanic eruption in the last 200 years,
humans were basically settled along the the southern and eastern shore of a,
of Africa huddled there to survive in the Emma Curtis Marianna and thinks that
the,
the I the seashore saved humanity to via accessibility of a c seafood along the
shore.
Vegetables were wiped off for about a thousand years or there was a thousand
year volcanic winter and vegetables were difficult to come by and the inland
sources of animals were,
were sparse as well.
It turns out we may have survived on corms there.
A starchy plant is in the biome of south southern Africa,
curbs,
corms,
yes,
I've seen this written forms.
It's a carbohydrate containing,
I,
I hate to tell the Paleo guys this
between the muscles and the,
and the washed up seals and an occasional beached whale and the seabirds and
occasionally inland hunting.
Um,
that that was basically how we survive muscles,
muscles or your friend and both,
both kinds of muscles.
So,
so there's the survival aspect of the Dha of course in the seafood became a
substrate for them,
for the brain.
And you can see they're remarkable photos that show the difference between a
100,000 years difference in the human skull.
So profound difference.
You can see that the human skull,
the modern human skull than emerged is kind of a,
uh,
juvenile lies version of the earlier skull.
And,
uh,
the hyper prefrontal area of the cortex in what have you.
So bringing expansion clearly occurred in response to two things.
The availability of new nutrition to help propel brain growth.
The need to have high bring cognitive power to survive the ice ages plus the
growing settlement size on the seashore because we now had a stable source of,
uh,
food.
We,
I'm thinking of us,
you know,
coming from that period and that,
that spurred technology and remember language developed at this time too.
So it was an enormous change in human behavior during this time period.
And so we were talking about the interventions.
You mentioned eating two times a day and we'll,
we'll come back to this I think,
but is that generally breakfast,
dinner,
lunch,
dinner?
What's the,
what is your split look like?
Well,
whatever suits you,
but I do lunch.
I do,
I do breakfast dinner because I want a long interval between meals to promote
proteostasis.
I want that went to clear the enzymes.
I want to remember you got there about a billion's proteins in a cell according
to gentleman's group up at Berkeley.
Oh,
Berkeley.
And uh,
it's very critical to the,
the,
the degradation of the genes is sort of a continuous process,
but the transcription in making new proteins is,
is interval based kind of thing.
It depends on when the nurture and signals are there.
When,
when,
when Mtwara begins to say,
okay,
don't consume proteins,
make new ones transcribe and translate.
Although when you transcribe and translate you,
you find that that moves up a diagonal there for the atrophy process follows it
because you've got to keep some kind of balance there if you over,
my theory is this,
if we we,
we had to overeat in order to survive.
We don't live on energy balance and if you look at this as a random world,
you can't survive unless you overeat during periods when food is available.
So as to the store of nutrients for the time to scarcity,
we also over proliferate.
That is when new change surveillance will,
that transcription and translation process turns on in a sort of a burst has to
be because otherwise you won't make enough proteins to survive.
Your cells won't be durable.
That is what's killing us today because we're over transcribing or over eating.
We're making too many proteins.
They get misfolded,
they get damaged,
they don't,
there's no room for them.
This,
the architecture of the cell is stretched to the Actin.
Filaments are stretched out and there's stress signaling going on and you don't
transcribe accurately,
you know,
make good proteins when you're under stress.
We also talked then about the low mitochondrial density near stem cell niches.
I guess he said,
yes,
they reside in a low oxygen niche.
So how do you,
uh,
how do you proactively encourage low mitochondrial density in those areas?
You do weightlifting.
You stay off the treadmill.
Actually,
if,
if you sprint,
you can use up,
you can consume mitochondria because you,
you improve mitochondrial dense
quality.
I got it.
So they become more sort of effective and efficient.
So they don't need,
you don't need the density.
That's right.
That's why.
And,
and they are not as,
they don't realize much on observation either.
You're using the glycolytic pathway,
which goes through the Mitochondria anyway in Bethesda in the Kreb cycle and so
forth.
But it's not,
it's not producing lots of free radicals.
Are you responsible for getting a Nassim Taleb deadlifting?
Is that my fault?
Well,
you remember the story about now seeing my,
if you've,
if you read the back section of the little section you wrote for my book,
because he hear he was a kurtosis trader that as he,
he used distributions with wild characteristics.
He was,
he was buying out of the money calls and puts
and living on the variance.
Right.
He was,
I weren't living in the options world.
Yes,
that's right.
And so here he was doing just steady state exercise.
And I said,
what,
what are you doing?
This is the wrong approach.
Just I just so I know it because I,
and uh,
how did you first,
how did the two of you connect?
I used his book in a class.
I taught a fool by randomness.
I used in a class,
I taught on the economics of uncertainty.
It's all them.
I communicated with him,
I said,
I'm using your book.
I don't know why Rhodium but I,
because I hate textbooks
and they're really connected with him.
He said he hates textbooks to you,
really,
you really hit a sore spot,
get him started on ACA academia.
So
she connected with him and then he was doing steady state exercise.
He was,
he was doing his,
you know,
three sets of 12 and so many hours on the treadmill or the cycling or whatever.
And he figured out that in cycling to and from his office,
that's when he,
his office was some distance from his own gym.
He said he figured out that the maximum expenditure of energy and that ride was
within them the most good.
And that's,
that's your approach to this four hours.
For example,
in an organization,
the meeting,
the,
the half the work is done by the square root of n workers.
So he got a hundred people in there,
10 workers produce half the output,
which catch,
I mean,
this is,
we're on the same page with this parade of distribution.
Right.
And this is just solar prices work in Lufkin and others have looked at
scientific publishing,
publishing,
what have you.
Uh,
the pope has his own own version of this,
by the way.
Hope John Pope John Paul,
before,
before he passed away,
he was asked how many people work at the Vatican.
He said about half of them.
Of course,
Robert Evans,
just a,
it's the same thing about Hollywood.
Hollywood is a place where half the people are not working.
And it's true that between films and they're hoping for the next one.
So even Dustin Hoffman is great.
You said I have to be grateful to be working.
Uh,
this goes with the business in the industry.
There are these power law distributed networks and a few people that are with us
and we'll hubs.
And so James,
the same rule really holds for the movie industry.
And probably half the people do.
About 10% of the people do about half,
half the movies or something like that incident that's not seem thought that
the,
the calorie expenditure during his bike ride as what was giving him the most
bang for the buck.
Can you imagine the people were that dumb back in those days?
And there's still people around who think that,
uh,
the energy balance model,
I don't know how well let's face it.
They all studied steady state exercise because you put someone on the treadmill
and you,
Benji does option expenditure.
Nobody had any idea.
Nonsteady state exercise is very difficult to quantify and dementia now they're
getting better at it once much better at it.
And he was,
the power law holds again because the most intense exercise,
the most intense expenditures to the ball.
You put accelerometers on children,
the leanness of the ones who engage in the most intense verse,
they little little children don't steady state exercise.
So what does your exercise regimen look like or what you would prescribe to
someone like a not seem or anyone?
Well,
I told
the shame to start doing negative dead lifts.
If he wants to improve his dead lifts have have somebody help you put the bar
up,
lower it,
pick,
pick a height and then put it up.
You can lower it again and put it up,
Lord again.
I do.
I do almost all negatives now.
Why is that?
You talk about why,
why?
Why are you centrics?
Well,
so I'm doing eccentrics for really three reasons.
The main one being the fake double your stem cell counts in the satellite cells
and the muscle.
Now the double loan,
but they don't exhaust him.
A lot of people,
if you double the stem cells,
it flood out.
You may exhaust them because you made simply exhausted the ones in the niche
which you want to do is you want to double them and have one go back into the
nation.
One go out and and Hugh of tissues,
asymmetric differentiation is what you want.
If he symmetrically differentiate,
they both become new possible progenitors to cells.
You,
you're now exhausting.
Put what?
Take one out,
put one in it is the best way to do it.
And Accenture cash science does that downhill running just to downhill running
down.
He ramming.
How do you in,
uh,
so I'd love to hear what a,
a,
a negative focused workout of yours might look like.
And if you could also just talk about mitigating injury risk because there are a
lot of people who get in.
For instance,
there are a lot of sprinters who in their training will only do the positive on
deadlifts and dropped them for fear of hamstring injuries.
So,
so not as,
they can't be done safely because I,
I've done a lot of natives,
but I'd love to hear what a workout of yours looks like.
It's so mild you wouldn't believe you and I work off in a almost every day.
Okay.
Maybe 10,
15 minutes.
And uh,
sometimes it's hard to do a negative if you don't have a training partner.
But I use equipment and I use,
uh,
like for example,
they extensions push up with two lower than with one typical lake press push up
with two lower with one.
Um,
shoulder presses push up with two.
Actually I,
I use,
I use a machine and in this case they're like the power hammer stuff of push it
up and lower with one
dealt with weights are all fast,
which are mostly from fast,
which fibers.
So they really responded well well to that.
Um,
what body,
just since you mentioned it,
which muscle groups respond best to this type of training?
All of them.
Postural muscles,
they're slow twitch fibers.
You need to,
they need to have endurance.
Keep your posture locked in his,
sorry,
I end every workout standing against the wall.
And then this was the thing that neval like most about my seminar.
Standing against the wall,
you know,
get,
get a little slot in the smaller your back.
Put your heels and butt against the wall and your shoulders back,
your head back.
Walk off and leave.
Look over your cheekbones.
Don't lift,
don't drop your head and start looking down.
Your whole spine collapses.
So look straight ahead.
If you need to look down,
just look down over your cheekbones.
Don't drop it.
Just sent your head and the rest of you.
So this is to establish proper posture.
It is to establish proper foster,
but also to maintain it and to have a sort of nobility,
having good posture.
It really makes a difference in your mental attitude.
Are you working your entire body every,
uh,
your entire body every day?
No,
I'm not because I may want to.
I might do lakes in show.
It was one day and I almost never do curls because it just ego and muscles
anyway.
But,
um,
I would just go around and do a variety of exercises.
I make sure to get everybody group a couple of times a week and I'm cycling
through and I do a lot of laughs and a lower back and leg work.
And the shoulder work.
When you in season 10 to 15 minutes,
how do you choose,
let's just take an example in the shoulder press.
Uh,
how are you determining what week to use?
Is it a percentage of say one rep concentric,
uh,
and then what is the tempo number of repetitions?
If you could just give us,
give us an idea of,
of the programming of that.
I'm such an instinct or trading trainer.
Like Arnold Diaz.
Yeah.
Um,
I might,
I just don't have a regular way.
I just do it.
Okay.
Do you go to the point where you start to lose the ability to control the
descent or when do you terminate as I do,
I have some sense of fatigue,
but what I do is I push it up really fast and quickly and very precise form,
very lots of acceleration and then coming down really slow.
And if to a full good stretch,
you have to,
if you remember,
we have this giant protein in your muscles is tightened protein.
It's the stress sensor.
And stress,
by the way,
will stimulate [inaudible] in protein synthesis.
The stretch.
Yes.
That's the,
is that I might be getting this wrong myotonic reflex.
Am I getting there on something that I don't know what I'm talking about?
Please continue.
Yeah.
I want to,
okay.
Well there's a signaling domain down in the,
and,
uh,
the titan protein passes.
It sets the architecture of the home muscle really,
and that,
and the action.
If there's,
there's a Cytoskeleton,
a skeleton in the muscle itself and these acting fibers,
and if their struts and send,
if they send stretching you,
you get the dystrophin protein.
This senses the,
the distortion
of the,
um,
of the enclosure of the muscle.
And then at the titans senses the extension in the muscle.
That means you want to really go for two a full stretch.
If you actually anxious,
if you did curls and never fully stretched,
you would,
you'd have a little tiny muscle.
You've got to stretch the muscle out in Goldberg's work in all of it.
All kinds of work on muscle shows that full extension you lengthen the muscle to
on linkedin.
Muscle is stronger and fuller when it's contracted and it's faster.
So I go,
I want my muscles to be not too big.
Lean.
Well in quick what,
uh,
from a distant evolutionary template,
what would have mimicked the centrics aside from downhill running?
What actually any kind of running does it as you know,
because every impact,
eccentric,
uh,
stress,
any kind of lowering,
of course you had to lift and lower things.
Um,
I suppose care even carrying is a certain degree of a eccentric exercise,
but I only see this is,
this is stone age plus high tech and high tech.
Part of it is looked at Macaluso looses work on stem cell
activation.
I'm going to start to work on it as well.
I want an efficient time,
time efficient exercise,
keep me injury free.
Entry free is really very important.
I've had almost no injuries in,
in the gym over 60 years using using gems.
I can think of one when,
when the injury,
so you're efficient injury-free the fast,
which type of fibers are the ones that you're hitting when you do descending and
when you get older,
your motor neurons aren't as effective.
So you want to have the kind of heavy stimulation of the vast,
which fibers,
they're the ones that have the biggest motor neurons.
And the way to do that as negatives I there is a very safe,
very effective,
of course you can't do negatives on everything because you know,
it's awkward and uh,
what have you.
So you can,
you can at least concentrate on accelerating smoothly and rapidly up and then
descending slowly.
I mean,
Doug McGuff this sort of stuff and they're probably the best thing about his
exercise is the slow descent.
Yeah.
But I would never work out hard enough where I have to rest a whole week.
I do something every day.
What's the,
uh,
what's the rationale behind behind that as opposed to having longer rest
intervals?
Okay.
Well I want to renewal signal every day.
The renewal signal is one,
it's,
it's the fasting before exercise.
Then the fasted.
When do you work out typically?
When do you do this?
15 minutes of
a out at 11 o'clock in the morning typically.
So if he got it,
so I'll get up at like seven or six and I'll have a,
a mild breakfast at like eight.
What would be,
would be some of your default breakfasts?
Well,
my favorite default of breakfast is a giant swell,
tricky lake
with a bit of Mellon.
Uh,
they're very inexpensive and they're fun to eat.
Sounds fantastic.
I wish I had some of that here.
Unfortunately,
I did not go to two big Turkey legs package at Walmart even,
and a w one,
one Turkey leg and maybe half a third of a melon.
Got It.
And then,
uh,
I will work out at 11.
I'll have a 15,
20 minute workouts because I like to go around and see if there any girls
Saturday at two while I'm there.
And uh,
I won't eat until four hours after I'll eat like at five o'clock.
Got It.
So that's your,
that's your evening meal and then you don't eat between five.
And when do you typically go to sleep?
I might go to bed at 11.
Okay.
All right.
No,
but so you,
so you'd finish your last meal by say six o'clock and then have four or five
hours of fasting before bed?
That's correct.
Got It.
Okay.
I won't eat,
tell,
you know,
maybe even lunch the next day.
It just depends.
Got It.
I'm just taking,
I never have three meals a day.
I sometimes have,
um,
uh,
one,
sometimes none.
Most Times too,
but you don't have to cut calories.
It's just the timing.
It's the intervals between meals where you have low insulin signalling,
high atop g and proteostasis mechanisms.
Like the proteasome is eating up enzymes and you're clearing the damage.
You're,
you're a topics you peaks at about four hours after four to six hours,
uh,
after,
um,
exercise.
I hope these guys who who guzzle right after the,
after their workout,
they're killing,
they're killing the adaptive process.
You can't have without a proper Tawfiq g your muscles degenerate.
You have to clear the old damaged proteins and that's how you do it.
Then the proteasome is that little core shape,
barrel shaped object in the,
in the cell that that consumes mostly enzymes that have done their job clears
enzymes.
If you have enzymes to stay there too long or are our neuro neuro factors of
some kind like Lincoln stress hormones,
you have to eat those up.
The whole thing is dynamic protein generation and clearance.
So what I'm doing is I'm working out,
I'm stimulating the topic you process and the prettiest Stacey's PR proteostasis
is protein quality maintenance process.
So by full,
four hours later,
that's,
that's B,
it's over and I'm good and hungry.
I have a nice big meal.
What does dinner look like?
Would be an example of a,
of a dinner that you enjoy.
But I'll have my wife hands me something and usually it's a,
I used to do all my own cooking when,
when after my first wife passed away.
But uh,
now she's such a great cook of the,
have a big mound of a Spanish with lots of garlic in it and uh,
they may be,
uh,
she makes a lot of pot roast her own way though,
has won an Italian way.
Um,
of course a fair not amount of steak.
I'll have an occasional prime rib,
but I always cut the excess fat off.
I don't like fatty beats.
Is that just a personal preference or is there a,
is there a scientific reason behind her is just palette?
It's both.
It's both personal.
I,
I trust my taste and if,
if something is just like,
oh,
this is too much of this,
uh,
the back off it.
The other part of it is if,
um,
if you want to have a fatty liver,
you Elana fat,
there's no way around it.
Got It.
Yeah.
You know your oxidized energy sources according to how easy the RDX oxidize.
So first carbohydrate goes.
Then maybe protein or fat but fast elastico so it has to go somewhere.
And excess adipose tissues,
one of the worst things you can do.
My body composition so crucial,
and if you get your liver starts filling up with that,
this is fat where it shouldn't be this topic fat and it built,
then it's also building up in your bone marrow,
in your muscle and your thymus,
you know in your brain.
So there's fatty degeneration is a source of stem cell differentiation.
Stem stem cell will come wandering out and say,
I'm going to fix this muscle,
but it encounters of a lot of fat in the muscle so it differentiates into an
adipocyte instead of muscles.
Remember these stem cells are burnt plastic.
They can take on a fete depending on the tissue they arrive to and what signals
they receive.
Their local,
it's local as well as the global signals that are causing them seek body bill is
always knew it was volume that build mass.
I think this is really generally true.
You lots and lots of volume.
Even two workouts a day they used,
I was around a lot of these guys.
Sure.
I get the volume in a different way.
I work out everyday,
but maybe 20 minutes at the most.
Right.
I do take one day.
I don't work out at all.
What do some people in the Paleo Movement get wrong?
What do you think of the most common errors are logical fallacies or,
or,
uh,
damaging fads or trends that you observe and
people who self identify as Paleo.
Very interesting.
Uh,
because they are,
there are a lot of little tribes inside.
Oh sure.
A lot of factions.
And I don't,
frankly,
I don't keep track of these guys to just too many people trying to say too many
things.
They eat too much fat.
Absolutely true.
They,
a lot of them went off while wildly ended the,
into fat consumption.
So they probably have fatty liver,
spleen.
Now I really,
I mean,
you cannot eat large amounts of fat and not have a fatty liver.
You can't look at the Internet.
Who needs all the energy they're trying to,
they're worried about energy balance.
I don't get worried about energy balance to you.
They uh,
they think there are particular kinds of foods they have to eat,
but really variety and
flavor,
texture,
color.
That's,
that's how you choose your meals.
What,
what are your thoughts on,
I,
I love your Facebook page by the way.
I do have questions about why you got rid of your blog,
but I,
your Facebook has sort of information density than I've seen in almost any other
Facebook page.
And uh,
what are your thoughts on coconut oil and coconut products?
I wouldn't do it.
You wouldn't do it.
Now does that come back to the fatty liver and just a percentage of your total
intake is as fat?
Well,
first of all,
it's,
it's an evolutionary nonsequitor doesn't follow you.
You wouldn't not be seeing large amounts of coconut
consumption in the Paleolithic.
So it that it,
it's just odd verse the fall and it's kind of a fad second of all.
And there,
who knows that the manufacturers of these things are all shines of impurities.
So theater involved,
um,
it doesn't taste good either.
I don't think you go,
I'll confess.
I'm pretty second.
Coconut has got so much fat in it already.
Why would you ever need to have any additional source of fat and the evening
olive oil I'm sparing with
do you cook eggs or do you consume eggs?
Sure you do.
How do you prepare your eggs?
Fried.
Boiled scramble.
So if you,
if you fry them,
what are you using to fry in or scrambled?
What uh,
are you using a small amount of olive oil using butter?
Are you using
small amount of olive oil and then a moderate temperature?
And I don't know.
Actually I haven't seen my wife cooking the h lately.
I don't know how she does
oil free would be perfectly fine with me.
If you had a pan that one of these ceramic pans that,
uh,
we're think slide off,
she never burns a Nagy there and they're always wonderfully done.
I used to throw a yoke away when I'd eat four boiled eggs,
you know,
would do you,
would
you still do that if you are consuming eggs?
I find the Yolk Fifth Arden in chased and I don't like two months ago,
but I,
I,
but I don't throw,
but it gets tired of ancient,
very tired very quickly.
Got It.
Yeah.
I found a,
I love eggs,
but they only recently discovered a few years ago.
Uh,
and it's so simple how to make proper soft boiled eggs so you have a nice
delicious yolk as opposed to the yellow golf ball of the hard boiled,
which is just so chunky and unpleasant.
Yes.
So let's talk a little bit about,
you mentioned the,
the consumption of say post workout carbohydrates and amino acids or whatever it
might be.
A love to chat a little bit about [inaudible].
So this is,
this is a big subject and a lot of people are trying to minimize am tor
activation in the,
in the hope of extending lifespan and health span.
And uh,
so I'd love in general,
here are your thoughts on,
on that where people are,
say,
doing everything they can to minimize activation of mtor and they're trying to
remove a leucine.
They're trying to get their IGF one is lowest possible.
Uh,
so thoughts in general and I'm torn.
Then also on the use of say,
rapamycin or Metformin will look
over proliferation or hyper proliferation is considered to be one of the evils
of modern world,
but it was a necessary adaptation in the past.
You couldn't have survived if you didn't proliferate rapidly in the presence of
food because you wouldn't have got a chance later on.
You had to be very effective at doing that,
but there would have been in the evolutionary times that would have been a
protein quality control process following that,
because you've had a fairly long interval without food,
so over driving him toward was never a problem.
They're talking in the modern world about people who were never shut him off.
Basically,
if you don't have these intervals between meals and you're over driving em
Taurus,
so you're creating lots of misfolded proteins,
proteostasis is collapsing.
The first thing is si elegans does when it starts to die as his proteostasis
collapses.
Sealing and [inaudible] are our favorite worm.
Yes,
for a lot of studies.
So you don't want your proteostasis to collapse.
It's not going to collapse.
If you have these intervals between meals.
If you don't turn on an tour,
your immunity is not going to function properly because you proliferate the
year,
your five ascites and your your t cells,
your whole immune system.
RAPPA.
Meissen isn't immune suppression as president,
right?
Yeah.
Because you're shutting down m tour.
All toxins shutdown him tour
because you can't try and transcribe in the presence of a toxin or are you going
to proliferate that the torch and is going to invade all the new tissues you're
making.
So proliferation in mtor and inventories of the whole thing.
By the way,
you stimulate him to order through mechanical stress.
When you,
when you're,
when you're consuming damaged proteins inside yourself indoors being signaled,
why is that the case will,
because those protocols,
amino acids are now available and you have to have that because if you don't,
you don't.
The innate immune,
the an innate stress response can't be activated.
Gene transcription changes when you're under stress,
first of all,
because you don't want to make proteins in a stressful situation.
Second of all,
you have to encode other genes to month.
The stress response and him towards doing that because it's getting the amino
acids if you're coming from the proteostasis process,
so if,
if they want a chronically turned down the MTR,
they're gonna,
they're gonna to waste away.
You need IGF one in the rescue of neurons that are struggling and stressed and
you make IGF one locally,
not they're confusing systemic IGF that is in the serum,
in the blood,
right from the local.
There's local signaling and there's
global cycling is some sense and in the circulation and you're getting your
global signals,
but in the,
in the muscle or in the brain,
when you activate,
when you used,
when you exercise your muscles,
you actually create local Iga of one that doesn't necessarily go out into the
bloodstream.
I have very low serum IGF one,
but I have lots of muscle in it because I make it locally.
I had a doctor looked at me and said,
you can't have that kind of muscle and have such low IGF one.
And I said,
well,
am I make it locally
where he's used to seeing national wrestlers and so forth stoking up on insulin
and other such things?
Right?
Well,
it's kind of like all the,
uh,
all the hipsters in San Francisco or they say think globally by locally.
We'll say you're thinking globally and making your IGF
thick.
I make it locally,
but you know what?
A muscle contraction will,
will turn on Akt.
And so you're not coming through the insulin pathway,
but the second half of the year,
rescuing Akt as a survival hormone,
survival and protein there,
they're thinking about the insulin pathway exclusively.
But you got other factors down there.
There's a wonderful work done by a Japanese Isand,
Merona [inaudible] and others who show that if you can overexpress a Katie in
the muscle,
that's,
that's protein kinase B also,
or whatever it is they have,
um,
it'll heal your liver.
So exercise your muscles and heal your liver.
And how do you do that?
You Express Akt and the fast twitch muscle fibers.
So in those studies,
were these researchers using a high intensity weightlifting protocol?
No.
There was merely engineering the genes in the mouse to overexpress a KT and the
fast twitch fibers.
Profoundly effective,
profoundly effective.
You can't read that,
aren't study a series of studies by this group as a mirror.
And uh,
you can't read that without saying,
I want all the fast twitch fibers.
I can have it.
They're not a leak disposing glucose.
They're taking the glucose disposal burden off the liver,
right?
And off the brain.
So these insulin like peptides that are signaling in the brain too often you're,
you're turning,
turning on down because of the,
you're taking their glucose disposal burden off the other cells and therefore
you're reducing insulin signaling and those cells.
And it turns out that when you contract muscle,
you make this a four B,
e p e or something like that,
which interrupts trans transcription.
What you want to do is you want to have,
you don't want to beach and transcribing new proteins in your brain when it's
not time to do.
So.
You want to be improving the quality of the neurons.
So if you,
if you exercise,
you reduce transcription in other cells because this particular protein that
binds to m Tory and keeps it from initiating transcription,
the if things of m four does amp tours overreaching in any way?
It's um,
it's the,
it's the ribosome that really matters.
Please Mr what will tell us more about the Ribas zone?
Well,
the reivers zone and uh,
yeah,
if you could make it as a start a start at the basics.
Okay.
Well and I could blame that on my audience and say for those who don't know,
but like I would actually like to have to get myself,
well when you're going to make a new protein that messenger RNA comes out,
it's a string.
The reivers zone is just a little beat led structure that runs across the string
and it's,
it's charged with amino acids.
It reads the signals on the Messenger Rna and its transcribes these long strings
to proteins.
Then they go off and they go live and then they're folded and what have you.
It's actually like a universal Turing machine remembered challenge.
Alan Turing said you can,
you can make any computer if you just have a rewriter head and a tape
test with the ribosome is,
is the ReadWrite head that runs along the tape and makes proteins.
My neighbor UCI was the world's leading expert on Ribas zones.
God is so complicated,
it gives you a headache every time I've talked to him.
So I finally came up with this idea,
well,
it's a term universal turning machine.
It's going across the,
the re-tape is a messenger RNA.
The right tape is that the protein that is made is by the,
by the ribosomes.
Well,
the reivers zone
commonly been very complicated.
It's very adaptive in how,
what would it transcribes?
So Fox,
that will change the transcription factors.
So therefore change that in this messenger RNA and the reivers zone were run
across there.
And between those two that are like any universal computer is,
is inheriting what they can do.
So you change the transcription factor,
you wrinkle up the DNA a little bit and and expose other areas for
transcription.
And the reivers zone is what is the coding factor that handles the integrated
stress response protein transcription changes toward instead of making new
proteins,
you're making these stress responsive factors and that's it.
That's,
that's integral to the,
to the survival process that happens in as a in response to resistance training
or,
yes.
Got It.
Yes it does.
You're make Fox so you all through the transcription of your DNA,
you'll make new messenger RNA and the bribe a zone.
If it's a sense of stress in the cell,
it'll begin transcribing these protective factors instead of like making all new
proteins.
It'll switch.
Andrew Dillon is a wonderful paper on that.
Uh,
his group is taking the,
where is he based or where does this team,
Berkeley,
Berkeley man.
My back yard is right up there in the bay area.
You may be a UC San Francisco.
He has,
he has a quantitative biology group there.
And so in doing that then in shifting the transcription to what you were just
describing to the survival,
yes.
Porous or stress response,
stress response factors,
factors.
We're bolstering that renewal program.
Yes.
The failure of which is implicated for what we call aging.
That's precisely right at your immunity is brought up also during this,
everybody,
everybody who does anything in aging these days is finally agreed.
Basically,
it's a stress response that that's what keeps you going,
that that maintains the cells,
protects them.
And uh,
hormesis
is like just one if they wanted to leave it on all the time,
but that would exhaust you.
You can't,
you can't.
The poised for every possible kind of damage Reber the,
the world's full of
maybe trillions of different kinds of damage that can happen to you.
And you can't have a precisely tuned damage response to each threat.
They have to be generalized and they're generalized through certain
transcription factors.
And through the way the FRY persona makes proteins.
So these generalized stress responses,
they're right across the immune system.
They run across the stem cell system,
they run across the protein synthesis across survivors zone.
All of these pathways intersect and every one of them in coats,
some kind of stress response,
cell protective pathway that's responding to a toxin,
rapamycin to a,
a bacteria.
The thing you don't want to have happen is when a bacteria is in there,
you don't want to be transcribing proteins,
have a bacteria we'll get into,
then you'll be making proteins for the bacteria.
So you've gotta be able to shut down transcription at the right time.
But if you can't shut down transcription or [inaudible] toric completely because
then you can't make the defensive factors that are required.
And there,
this is where these micro RNA seem to come in.
Are you interested or not interested in say intermittent use of something like
rapamycin?
Do you find,
do you find that,
is that just trying to make a deal with the devil?
Is that,
are there too many unknowns or is,
is is something like that interesting to you?
To me,
I,
I don't,
it's a deal with the devil.
Okay.
I haven't even had a colon in 40 years,
so I want to invest my immune system.
So,
aside from the
the,
let's say the,
the way that you eat and the spacing of your meals that we discussed and the
resistance training,
what other factors are behaviors,
interventions,
do you think have contributed to not being sick for decades?
Stay away from pill people.
Stay away from people
of what I could.
When I was teaching at the university,
I had a class with 400 people in it and half of them had just gotten back from
China and were coughing and sneezing and so forth.
I was sort of the universal substitute teacher because everyone else got sick
and they knew art wouldn't be sick.
They'd call me off to go teach your classes.
It's,
it's,
it's spooky in a way.
So do you,
is it just
picking,
you're picking your parents wisely or is it a,
is there,
is there more,
are there other factors,
other factors?
Like you expose yourself to some coal.
Hmm.
You stretch your muscle,
you,
uh,
you get plenty of good sleep,
very important.
You've it and you kind of have
these functional m tore windows during your sleep.
You've gotta,
you've gotta live in one window of the other.
Is it growth repair window?
It's Lynn window and there's the Fox though.
Window insulin tor versus Foxhall as how I see my my life and I'm going from one
window to the,
uh,
the cause.
It can't smell be Voxa,
Etho exome,
s four kit box
proteins.
Therefore human versions of it.
So important in your cognitive function,
which starving Fox and what makes you want to move
the Fox who would do for you then would be part of good sleep,
which is why you're not going to eat within four or five hours.
I'm going to bed.
You're going to,
you're going to spend the first window of sleep,
sort of rebuilding tissues.
Second window of sleep,
you're into the start start foxo mode and you're also altering your synapsis.
There's an interesting new gene is called homer.
It counts if it floods into your brain.
Yet when your excitatory fact signaling is depressed,
not much glutamate in the neuron.
So homework got xen and it shrinks your synapsis.
It's very appropriately named.
That's hilarious.
It is hilarious as proportional
shrinking.
In other words,
you're going to say 10% each synapse is going to shrink by 10% the biggest
synopsis or the most active ones,
that's where post traumatic stress lives.
So if you can shrink those,
they have to be stable.
But if you keep rehearsing that same synapse constantly is going to grow in in
strength.
And people who reverberate thoughts in their mind or ruminate a lot fake it.
They get depressed because of those circuits.
According to jail,
they Edelman,
that's neural Darwinism.
The circles are Arwen is a neural Darwinism.
Darwin,
there's Darwinian competition going on inside your cells everywhere.
So for those people listening who do ruminate and a percentage rate,
that's another good word,
constantly and get depressed.
What,
what advice might you give them?
Star in exercise exercise now the,
the I you know you,
you seem like you have more to say.
So I'll leave.
Please continue.
Wellstar starboard exercise,
but to something that's totally different so that you,
you set up neurocircuits they compete with the ones that are ruminating and
building and strength in your,
in your brain that the starvation part of it is to eat up some of these,
some of these diff dysfunctional synapses that my saying is for every damaged
molecules there's a damage thought
and you're a depressed brain or a brain that is,
uh,
you know,
as post traumatic stress,
those are injured neurons inside the brain and you just need to get rid of the
dysfunctional molecules that are causing those neurons to malfunction.
So I guess,
yeah,
I mean,
I of course,
I mean it seems self evident,
but these people,
it goes,
it goes both ways,
right?
I mean,
for every damaged thought,
there's a damaged molecules if you asking about,
rather than trying to think your way out of that problem,
uh,
heal the brain first.
He'll Thursday deal their brain and you heal it with neurotrophic factors
outside,
be outside,
um,
new thoughts,
new new patterns of behavior.
How would you feel the sense,
silly to ask,
but how would you feed those new thoughts?
If a cave,
I loved one of yours was,
was getting depressed and exhibiting these symptoms,
what would you prescribe to them?
Well,
you know,
one of my first wife was,
was declining
from a whole host of other things.
I take her walk in as much as I could.
I would tell her bad jokes.
It changed their surrounding.
So you know,
the typical things that people have to do,
being outside is enormously effective there.
They're stimulii you can't even relate to you.
You bet you perceived him and your unconscious brain is what's going to heal
your first.
And the unconscious brain is more healthy when it's exposed to nature and a
happy people and children and dogs are DNR for our friend of all.
I think it's dumb thing I'm getting is attribution rate.
But he said the,
the first,
uh,
first rule of a conflict resolution or minimizing conflict is to not spend a lot
of time around people who are constantly in conflict.
Thought that was,
I thought that was a good rule.
Well our politics is exposed to that.
So turn off the news,
the news you mentioned in passing cold exposure.
So this is something that I've found to be tremendously,
uh,
effective in mood elevation,
among other things.
But how do you,
how do you expose yourself to cold?
Well,
I walk the dogs early in the morning with almost no jacket or anything.
Just,
just go out and get nice and chilly with him.
Cold showers there.
Where do you live now?
Oh,
southern Utah.
So it's not as cold,
no longer UCLA around camping.
No it's not.
But even,
even though if you live in a Jesuit,
like climate is cool in the morning.
Sure.
Quite cool.
In the morning.
Uh,
I keep the pool coal,
I don't heat the pool much.
Uh,
and I take cool.
I don't try to shock myself.
What,
so you then know,
this is may seem like a non sequitur,
which is most of my brain,
but,
uh,
we were talking about what you'd taught,
Nasim as it related to exercise.
Are there anything in any,
any particular things that you've learned from him or or PR and that could be
what you used his book to illustrate in your class or anything else?
Oh,
sure.
I mean,
he,
first of all,
he is a marvelous writer.
He tells stories in a way.
I could never tell that Tony and Tony,
right.
He creates marvelous characters that embody the kind of thinking he wants to
ridicule or,
or,
or power point out is,
you know,
savvy.
He likes street smarts like I do.
We both like mass smarts to,
I mean actual,
he went to the courant institute and he's very well trained mathematician far
better than I,
I guess.
Yeah.
We all need a black swan hunting device.
Is,
is some sin in some sense.
I could,
I tried to create a financial device,
crook for a partner who is too,
too dumb to be over,
take this anywhere.
But I've,
I've figured out ways of using Kurtosis to finance pharmaceuticals.
Could you define Kurtosis please and spell that?
It's a measure of the odd shape of the distribution.
It's high VP skewed off to the right or something.
It looks very non normal.
There's no assemble a Belfair no,
but it's a thing of beauty because if it's where life lives,
that's where life is in,
in that kind of at their fractal type distribution is like a parade or
distribution men.
Then they dropped down at the,
at the minimum.
Um,
see you reveal up that for a pharmaceutical development you said yes,
yes I had,
cause if the boom
I,
the last talk I gave at Harvard was between what's it compared to the movies to
pharmaceuticals.
And it turned out that they were the same kind of statistical distributions.
Lepto Crittenton it sounds like something you Chicago for.
It's actually a thing of beauty.
It's a skewed and biased to the right in with a very long heavy tail,
heavy tailed being.
Cause every tail is long in a sense.
But they become very thin.
It has a lot of probability out there.
That's um,
that's the true power law distribution of prey to distribution and so forth.
So it turns out pharmaceuticals that way because a few pharmaceutical cell,
billions and billions and billions of dollars or like $12 billion a year.
Most pharmaceutical sell about half a million or a billion maybe at most.
It's the big outliers that dominate the industry in ribbon hers.
So
using that skew,
you can design a swamp black instrument that uses the upper tail with pay the
lower tail.
And it,
if you,
if you divide it correctly,
you have a very favorable kind of gamble.
So his black would,
would uh,
tell EBS black swan hunting device then be derivatives training.
Would that be how or where would it be something in addition to that?
Actually you're the one that talks about that cause you're the guys just who's
found all the black swans with the startups.
Yeah,
I mean that's,
that's certainly my,
well,
I mean the way that we're going to maybe get off the reservation here for a
second,
but the way I've thought about that is because I do not have the mathematical
modeling background of you,
nor a Nasim or anybody else.
I,
it's not a funny story.
It's kind of a tragic story.
But 10th grade,
my brother and I had two different math teachers.
I had a math teacher who was very caustic,
um,
really had a chip on our shoulder and berated students.
Sounds like nursing.
Well,
he had a different response.
I think Nassim is more pugnacious than I am.
So,
so,
so he showed her his teacher.
I decided to choose my college based on lack of math requirement.
My brother had a fantastic teacher.
He now has a phd in statistics.
Oh,
isn't that something?
There's an extreme event right there.
A little small event.
But it really changed the course.
Yeah,
it,
uh,
it completely changed the course of my life.
And therefore in my case,
when I remember having a conversation with a hedge fund manager and there are
plenty of bad hedge fund managers out there and I don't think they go by that
name anymore,
but there are some very,
very brilliant people in the game.
And I spoke with one and I'm not going to get this totally right and uh,
and uh,
do it justice.
But he said,
you can have,
there are a number of different advantages you can have and you need to have at
least one.
And he said you can have an informational advantage,
analytical advantage.
You could have a,
uh,
say a behavioral advantage.
Meaning if you're someone like a,
there are plenty of people who try to imitate,
say buffet,
but they emotionally react to the market differently then above fear monger.
Sure.
And so on and so forth and are many of these.
And what I realized was,
given my sets of strengths and weaknesses where I could capitalize was in the
informational advantage by placing myself in the center of the switchbox in
Silicon Valley.
So that became my way of hunting for black swans.
Fantastic.
If you can handle the information load,
it is coming through there.
Well,
you know what was so odd about it in a sense or counterintuitive for a lot of
people,
I described this to and and uh,
not seem to actually informed my thinking a lot on this because,
and I'm again not going to do his description justice,
but thinking in a barbell fashion where I have the vast majority of my assets
and investments are cash or cash equivalents.
And then I have this smaller portion that is speculative but a very asymmetrical
returns.
If,
if,
if I can think through basic portfolio management properly.
And what I realized for myself is that I have an emotional disadvantage when it
comes to publicly traded anything.
I respond very poorly to,
uh,
compulsively despite knowing it's not my best interest.
Looking at watching people freak out and the sky is falling and then I become
chicken little and I sell at the worst time.
So what's,
what's fantastic about startups for me,
and I do not recommend this to anyone who does not have a significant advantage.
As I did that I would do all of my homework,
make a decision,
invest,
and then I couldn't sell.
It was a liquid and that turned out to be a very good thing.
I was locked in,
so I had to do all of my homework on the front end.
And then,
uh,
there was no ticker tape for me to watch,
no charge for me to watch really.
And,
uh,
it's,
it's just worked out fantastically.
I had a professor who was long and sugar when the Castro revolution hit
and he finally said,
I can't take it anymore.
I gotta clear my physician.
Oh man,
it's,
yeah,
no,
it's,
I'm really,
really,
really bad at anything that I can watch moving up and down.
So I need to address that in my own life and a lot of ways.
But,
so we're,
we're talking about,
uh,
well for instance,
talking about the,
the sugar position.
And I remember asking,
a friend of mine is a very good investor about liquidating certain positions or
not.
And he said,
well,
I think you should just look at,
as I was asking him for certain dollar ranges,
how he runs the math,
and he said,
I just sell down to sleep.
Uh,
sleep at night level.
That's exactly it.
So selling to sleep at night levels and uh,
you mentioned getting good sleep.
What are,
what are the things that you do or don't do to help ensure good sleep for
yourself?
Well,
here's probably the only supplement I take.
I do take some Melatonin,
Melatonin.
And do you take that on a daily basis?
Sometimes.
Uh,
but it's like I didn't bring any with me on a trip far right,
so forth.
I don't do anything right here,
but I'm Melatonin and as much more than just a sleep aid.
It's founding plants.
It's a resistance stress resistant to protein.
It does have powerful antioxidant properties,
but you need oxidants to AWC stocks.
Oxidative molecules are signaling molecules as well,
but you need a proper balance of signaling versus chronically seedling oxidative
molecules.
But there's some other direct itself.
I think it,
it stimulates autophagy in the brain or some of these more fundamental processes
that,
uh,
maybe it brings out a homer
out of his cave.
I know you are,
you how,
how do you think about dosing?
Is this cycle one milligram,
a three milligram?
Do you have any idea?
Um,
five,
sometimes 10.
Wow.
Okay.
So that's a dose that I would use if I flew to Hong Kong to correct my sleep
cycle.
Sure he would.
Yeah.
Few weeks and it would work.
But I don't do it for sleep.
I do it for the other things.
It does.
Got It.
And do you worry at all in this,
this has been a sort of certain things you,
you are not terribly interested in like rap bison.
Do you worry at all,
and this is the question that came to mind.
I haven't asked him directly,
but dumb,
uh,
who we know Dominic D'Agostino also uses Melatonin on a very,
very regular basis.
Do you worry about any type of negative feedback loop or tolerance development
or side effects from chronic use of Melatonin?
A lot of people do,
and I maybe I did at one time when I didn't know enough about it.
But actually it's not,
you're not going to shut down the pineal gland from making Melatonin because
you're,
because you're not releasing,
stimulating it to make it in the first place.
You're not,
you're,
you're thinking in terms of a hoe homeostatic balance.
No,
its own,
I'm not,
I'm thinking about it as a search that's springing up protective pathways I
think in a completely different way.
And I don't even take it to sleep.
I take it to Raul to keep my brain to summon homer.
Actually everything I think of,
I think in terms of those protective pathways,
immunity restore,
restoration pathways,
the whole,
the whole knowledge that I thought I had before is sort of out the window and
you're thinking in terms of these molecular pathways.
Let's,
I'd like to explore that a little bit.
And this is going to,
I'm sure uncover a fairly deep level of ignorance on my part.
But if we're thinking about,
I know very little about Melatonin,
uh,
but I have taken it in the past.
If,
if we're looking at say the,
how does production,
well,
I'm trying to frame this.
If I think of the,
the,
uh,
HP ta,
I think that the hype with Hypothalamus,
pituitary testosterone access and the ways that that can be disrupted.
If you supplement with say,
testosterone or,
uh,
leuteinizing hormone,
which I guess would be hcg when you're injecting it or taking it some other
form,
even if say,
testosterone or growth hormone or for that matter or released in surges,
it's not,
not continual,
right?
Much like Melatonin.
Um,
why wouldn't regular consumption of Melatonin?
Because,
uh,
some type of of Mount Malfunction and I just don't know if it's one thing in a,
in a large stream of,
of other elements that I don't know about.
I don't have the answer to that either.
It's first of all,
you're positing fifth.
There's a feedback.
No,
I haven't,
I don't know.
I'm just,
I'm not even positive.
I'm just asking.
Yup.
So I w I wouldn't necessarily pause it,
that feedback,
a pathway to begin with because I don't think it's a homeostatic ah,
balanced fair.
I don't think it's that the body attempts to maintain pulses are,
or,
uh,
a balance of mill the tone.
And I think it's,
you actually make it during the day too.
It's not,
it's not,
the sleep hormone is a defensive hormone.
I mean,
it's in plants,
plants,
so don't have to get their rest or sleep.
They're not moving around all their much.
Uh,
it's,
it's an ancient,
ancient hormone.
It's evolutionarily conserved across almost all species.
And,
uh,
I used to know a lot about it.
I haven't thought about it and it's been a while.
So you caught me a short short of knowledge.
Well,
maybe this is a,
a good place to talk about the,
the limits of human knowledge and,
uh,
for instance,
in reading,
uh,
the Black Swan Nassim talks about epistemological arrogance fair about.
And,
uh,
and I think just to give people an example of that,
just to bring it down
to a eat more easily interested level.
I very good friend of mine,
well,
a lot of doctors says any good doctor will generally say,
you know,
50% of what we know is wrong.
We just don't know which 50%.
Yeah.
So very true.
How do you think about human knowledge,
what we can know versus what we can't know?
Uh,
and then this very broad question,
but that,
that was one of the topics that a novel recommended bouncing around in this
conversation.
So,
uh,
I ended,
okay.
This is something that has caused me to go from taking a lot of supplements to
taking fewer supplements,
for instance,
because there's so many historical case studies of
carrots are good for us.
We think they improve eyesight,
we attributed to Beta carotene,
then we start taking mega doses of Beta carotene.
Oops.
It turns out there's a lot more to the story now.
We've created all of these yeah.
Unanticipated side effects.
Yeah.
I think even if you look at a static diagram,
I'm something like the [inaudible] pathway.
Like,
Gosh,
it's so complicated.
And then you realize and all they'll have to be in the right sequence to these
molecules,
have their move with the right speed and have the right doses and so forth.
You never be able to figure that out.
So what you have to do is you have to be an experimentalist maybe,
maybe on yourself,
like you and I do,
um,
vaping on your,
on your child or your dog on Molly.
I actually had to experiment on my child.
I didn't like to,
but I had to because the doctors were killing him.
So I don't want to get into that too much.
But you have to be willing to test hypotheses.
Why?
Why not just admit that nature knows a lot more than we do and try to live as
simple,
clean,
decent life and eat good food and go hungry now and then mimic,
mimic those patterns.
There's an error correction mechanism inside each one of us.
If you ere in terms of,
for example,
you make,
you make some bad cells,
some bad proteins are your,
some of your stem cells go bad.
Nature's down there cleaning and up because the other stem cell will kill it.
It'll consume it or shove it out of the niche.
Just like eagles get shoved out of,
you know,
Nestle's gets shoved out of the niche.
There's competition going on inside your body constantly.
And if you use competition to weed out the weak and the faulty and let the
strong survive.
So you really are your ideas or competing.
Also,
everything is a,
as a question of
variety pruning.
Competition pruning things.
Like I said,
God said,
I got these different species.
I'll send out,
let's,
let's see what's one,
which one is best,
which one gets through the ice age.
That's how you do it.
And you,
your body's constantly pruning your thoughts,
your motivations,
your rewards
and sleep was the way you,
you clean all that up.
So I want to shift gears a little bit.
I'll just ask,
uh,
some of what my audience knows is rapid fire questions.
Your answers don't need to be rapid,
but,
uh,
does this become the sort of the,
the,
the tail end of our chat.
What books have you gifted most to other people or recommended most other people
that,
are there any particular that come to mind?
Well,
I mean,
I gave all my library books to the local college,
the library,
and they were full of,
uh,
books.
I'm
not philosophy.
I've thrown my philosophy books away.
Why is that?
The pointless,
empty,
empty questions for the most part,
they're not testable hypotheses.
Got It.
Yeah.
I've been generous with my thoughts more than I have with my,
my books in a sense.
I've gifted the bulk of my knowledge that I've developed on my webpage in a my
first essay on evolutionary fitness and acknowledge their quote out there about
the Paleo lifestyle,
I think was a real gift I gave to a lot of people who've carried on and then
developed it further.
And I was,
wasn't the originator,
but Lauren and I were both sort of thinking about Loren Cordain and I were
thinking about these things simultaneously.
I kept telling him,
don't jog Lauren.
Don't jog.
Yeah,
I think he probably still doesn't think,
I'm sure he's quite healthy still.
Um,
so that's,
that's,
that's the primary gift.
And I gifted many dissertation topics to graduate students.
I've ran more graduate students at the universities where I work in.
Anyone else in the department.
The students were drawn,
joined to me,
but my ideas were kind of complicated and it was not necessarily a good
dissertation there in the,
in the usual sense.
Good News.
You have me as an advisor,
bad news.
It's a hard topic.
Are there any particular books that have a very heavily influenced you or books?
What,
what are books that you've,
uh,
re-read,
if any come to mind?
I actually read the Journal Literature.
I don't read very many books anymore.
Scientific literature.
Where do you go hunting for literature and how do you decide what to read?
Um,
I choose a topic and I,
I look very broadly at the topic from a mathematical point of view,
from a biological point of view,
which is what all my reading now I must to have a library of hour graphy is
getting close to 8,000 entries in this aging literature.
And what a goofy literature,
some of videos,
you know,
I mean it's,
there's some fantastic articles there and then there's just a lot of fluff and
redoing and reviews and,
and sometimes the article will,
the abstract of the article won't be as long as the listing of authors.
It's really a weird field.
A party party review.
Yeah.
They figured out how to get citations.
Economist never,
we don't call it through that much.
And yeah,
maybe one or two coauthors at the most.
Well,
I mean,
if,
uh,
humans respond to incentives,
right?
I,
uh,
is that mostly pub med?
What sources do you like to use?
Are you subscribing to particular journals themselves?
I still look professional marriages,
so I have access to
applications.
Yeah.
Not Bad.
Don't get into reading about diets.
It's an endless literature and is pretty lousy.
What are in the,
in the fields,
uh,
or field of aging longevity,
although I feel like that where it's kind of tainted,
but uh,
it is,
yeah,
life extension on that one too.
I don't even know what to what to call it,
but uh,
what are the current
wild goose chases in your opinion
or,
or areas that are
potential dead ends or things that are just getting way overblown in your mind?
I do think fees,
uh,
attempts to manipulate him tour are
kind of pointless.
If you're chronically shutdown AMG jar,
you're going to shrink to nothing.
You're not going to make new proteins.
It's windows.
So you got to have a,
you got to have these switches.
The most fruitful papers that I re talk about a pathway that crosses another one
and they have switches.
Your turn them on and off you age in this window,
you don't agent that windows one way to look at it.
Yeah,
yeah.
That's a helpful way to look at it.
Yeah.
So you just want to have the not anti aging.
You want to be defending or renewing.
But most people in today's life are renewing on a continuous basis and so
they're misfolding proteins and they're damaging the cells and building fat in
tissues where it doesn't belong and so forth.
So I think all these attempts to stall him our,
our,
uh,
really kind of weird,
you don't want to stall if you don't want to over proliferate,
but I actually want to be capable of proliferating when it's essential because
when you want to renew a cell or rebuild,
rebuild tissues,
you,
uh,
you'd have to be able to do that.
Bodybuilding and the whole,
that whole notion of regularity and chronic are totally wrong.
You got to have switches,
windows and you go back and forth,
you alternate,
you kind of alternating states is the way to think about things.
And the problem is some of the people have looked at,
for example,
since Cynthia Kenyon's work on the worms and so forth,
the foxo pathway,
there are lots of residual pathways from that.
Are There Fox four kid box genes that that were part of the development process?
They are now raise resident in the cells and can respond and defend and repair
of cell.
For example,
if you work out,
you crew you,
you trigger Fox p and foxy him proteins in your,
in your brain while they were in.
By workout you mean sprint or a resistance training?
Yeah,
you can jog if you want to,
if you want to kill some of your stem cells with them.
No,
you got to have variety.
You've got to do all of these things.
So I think the idea of switch switches and windows is going to come in.
Systemic signaling is the hottest new thing in,
in aging research,
which makes a lot of sense.
That is signaling at a distance.
I think the stem cell pathways are going to turn out to be just crucial and
very,
very important.
And if,
again,
am tourists sort of misplaced because we got,
we got so many sick people in the world,
it's bad to be average now in today's world it's really bad.
I've never had average looking tests,
you know,
and my
blood work or anything else.
And average is average is dangerous these days.
You mentioned,
uh,
so dangerous reminded me of one thing that you said in passing and I wanted to
just unpack it.
It may not be a long story,
but you,
you said,
I've never been injured in all these decades of weight training except for one
instance that I can remember.
What was the one instance what happened?
Oh man,
it was just this weird guy in the gym.
There are a lot of those here.
Yeah,
yeah,
I was going to say,
yeah.
Um,
here's the old,
he was a fireman and he worked out at the gym and he used to do these behind the
neck presses.
Oh,
right.
With the Barbell,
with a barbell.
So he's using some whiteness,
all that.
That's nothing.
I wasn't warmed up or anything.
I hopped on.
I said,
well,
that's easy.
And I and I did it and I pulled a muscle in my neck and it hurt for three
months.
What are,
what are things that you do to help minimize the likelihood of injury,
whether it's some type of warmup before you go into your,
uh,
your,
your negative work or otherwise?
Well,
first thing I don't warm up.
You don't warm up.
No.
Started working at now when I was [inaudible] go straight to your first work
set,
whatever that might be.
Yeah.
But it's usually sort of mild and I may start with my so called famous
hierarchical sets,
a lightweight 15 reps,
heavier weight,
eight reps,
a heavier weight.
Yet for Reps,
you're going right up the fiber,
high hierarchy,
slow,
intermediate,
fast twitch.
Now you're warm,
you're warm up more,
more rapidly.
If you do something that's reasonably intense and then the rest of the workout
and you're warm.
I work out early in the morning when it's cold or I used to and now,
now that I don't have a job anymore,
I'm desired.
I work out at 11 and,
and every,
every time I go the right sheet,
the same guy is an x body builder.
You can tell him he looks good.
He's still,
he's there for hours and I'm in and out.
I don't know who looks better.
I think I do,
but I'm leaner and he's just more bodybuilding looking,
flicking guy.
And they don't,
they don't look good when they're not flex.
They don't look good.
Let's face it.
You mean you don't look like the second trimester nominal?
Oh No,
no.
And uh,
just for all the bodybuilders in the audience,
it's done all of you.
But let's be honest,
if we look at some of the competitors when they're not flexed,
oh,
oh boy.
How long?
You know,
is it a boy or a girl?
That's right.
That's exactly right.
So I really,
I'm,
I'm there for a little adventure for a little bit of intensity,
not to get hurt.
So if you have long muscles,
you do a full range of motion,
you're not going to get hurt.
And you're also a generally,
at least on the,
on the negatives,
following a slow cadence.
Right.
I mean you're,
you're,
you might be raising it quickly,
but you're lowering it entirely under control.
Control can entirely under control,
but down to a full stretch,
right.
I haven't thinking,
I'm thinking tightened spring,
right.
There's a spring down there.
And so even if I'm doing positive exercises,
I will lower and I did a little,
not,
not a bounce cause fullstop balances are destructive,
but the little stretch balance,
right.
If you were to go back to teaching and you were to teach a freshman Undergrad,
actually it could be a freshman or a senior seminar,
so let's just say 15 to 40 students,
something like that.
Uh,
and you only have them once a week.
Let's say.
Let's say you have them once a week for three hours,
one semester,
what would you,
what would you teach them?
The economics of uncertainty.
Economics as to the last class I had developed theory UCI and I told him they
love that they love the class.
Economics of extreme events is really what it was.
Not Uncertainty,
the way it's taught by utility theory and all of this nice utility maximization
and expected this and expected that.
It's all nonsense.
It would,
it would be the economics of extreme events
if someone wanted to.
Since you're probably not going to teach that class anytime soon,
uh,
is,
if somebody wanted to explore that for themselves,
how would they self-educate any record,
any starting points that you'd recommend?
I class notes or somewhere.
Let me show.
You should definitely somehow crowd crowdfund getting this.
We start with my movie buff.
What was the title of that?
Hollywood?
Hollywood economics.
It covers a extreme events fairly,
fairly thoroughly.
In fact,
a lot of students looked at that.
I had other,
I had other readings as well,
or you could look at a climate science and look at the extreme climate theory,
extremes of climate fire variation and what happens.
You could look at the economics of storms and floods,
flood plain analysis,
so I would look at nature.
If you were to pick one of Naseem's books to start with,
would would you,
would you choose fooled by randomness or would it be one of the other?
I think students learn more from full by randomness.
The Black Swan is marvelous,
a as well.
Skin in the game.
It's probably going to be a terrific book too,
because you've got to have skin in the game.
Everybody knows that,
but they always ignore it.
Or you want to do a chap,
a Chinese fund,
you've got to put skinny with him.
Yeah,
yeah.
Oh yeah.
30%.
Or they want,
they want incentives aligned.
They won't just cut your knuckles off.
You know,
it's just,
it's more,
it's,
uh,
I,
so the,
the economics
of extreme events,
uh,
if you could put anything on a billboard,
you have a gigantic billboard and you can put a short message word,
couple of words,
sentences,
whatever,
to get out to millions of people.
What would that message be?
Or whatever you would put it on the billboard.
It could be anything.
Well,
I used to,
and my principles of economics teaching the importance of freedom and arbitrage
arbitrage keeps you from being stupid because you compare the price of this
relative to other equivalents are close substitutes or so forth.
If you do,
if you've talk mathematically about pricing,
you lose the anchoring from the arbitrage principle.
So I always taught arbitrage arbitrage.
Could you,
could you,
uh,
explain that maybe through an example,
I would just love to buy low
and sell high,
but you trade,
you have to trade different alternatives.
For example,
thanks.
Your pours a vacuum and economics,
uh,
pores and arbitrage opportunity arbitrage opportunities get eliminated.
Is that okay?
Gotta be,
is that just efficient?
Not Efficient market theory?
It's a,
a way of looking at efficient markets.
The best predictor of tomorrow's price of something is today's price because
that leaves no arbitrage opportunity.
Right?
If you knew the price is going up tomorrow,
we'd go up today.
You know,
that kind of thinking.
You think about opportunities where you think in terms of the arbitrage limits
that are there.
So I taught,
I taught general equilibrium theory as arbitrage.
Also.
It wasn't too successful.
It wasn't,
it wasn't appreciated.
But um,
this is how model involves general equilibrium theory.
Also ours,
it's the presence of arbitrage.
So would you just put
understand arbitrage,
would that be the message?
The Bill Borg?
Yeah.
Um,
no,
that it would be a freedom counts.
Freedom counts.
Yeah.
Freedom Matters.
And is that mostly in reference to markets or is,
is it freedom of contract and freedom of arbitrage,
freedom of venturing,
freedom of exit.
People don't have to be forced to do things.
They can exit,
they can think and participate.
Freedom counts.
Yeah,
I like that.
Uh,
what workouts to
lift heavy things and you know,
lift heavy things.
Freedom counts.
Well aren't,
we could talk for hours and hours and hours and a,
and then we're going to go,
go,
uh,
probably grab a bite to eat at some point after this.
But is there a,
is there anything,
and I'm going to ask you after this,
where people can learn more about you,
what you would like them to check out and certainly that'll all go in the show
notes.
But is there any or any parting words or suggestions or asks of my audience
something that they should test,
something they should consider,
anything that you'd like people to get ready to throw my,
for my book when it comes out on,
on aging as a field is full of a lot of charlatans.
There's some good science and there's some,
the rest of no such thing as successful aging because aging is damage.
So you can't be successful if you were being damaged.
And do you have a,
do you have a set timeline for that or a,
a titles people should look out for?
Or should we just say prime yourselves?
It's coming and we will let you know when it comes out,
you know,
check,
just check my Facebook page.
That's,
that's my law.
I've given up my blog.
It wasn't worth the time and effort.
I did help a lot of people,
but that passed that.
Now I,
I've,
I've taken up this as a really is a scientific quest because one,
like I said,
I'm experienced coming up,
coming up on aging on 80 is um,
you start thinking about,
you know,
when you approached Middle Age,
you started thinking about these things when you wait,
so you're planning,
you're planning your next 80,
the possibility the technology is coming and it is there right now inside each
person in,
it's the protein quality controls.
So quality control,
don't lose cells,
maintain them,
starve them there.
Within a while that's good for them.
So the technology,
I am applying the technology and I think I'm,
I'm,
I'm doing pretty well at it so far.
I do plan to live another 40 60 years.
I think you're doing pretty well and your arms are bulging out of your shirt,
which is long sleeved.
So I think things are going well.
Well Art,
thank you so much for the time.
I really appreciate it and uh,
this is,
this has been a lot of fun and for everybody listening,
as always you can find links to everything that we've discussed.
Okay.
[inaudible] Facebook page and more at Facebook,
not Facebook.
Let's try that again.
Four hour work week.com forward slash
podcasts
or tim.blog/podcast they both go to the same place and you will find show notes
for this episode and every other episode.
And
until next time,
thank you for listening.
Hey guys,
this is Tim again.
Just a few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email from me every Friday that provides a
little more soul of fun before the weekend and five bullet Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the,
uh,
the world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles
that I've read and that I've shared with my close friends for instance.
And it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to a four hour work week.com that's four hour workweek.com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you will get the very next one.
And if you sign up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought to you by audible,
which I've used for many,
many years.
I absolutely love audio books in there.
One of my favorite ways to pass the time when I travel.
I'm on the road all the time and audible allows me to consume many more books
than I possibly could otherwise I have to audio books to recommend right off the
bat.
The first is perhaps my favorite audio book of all time and it's the only
audiobook I've wanted to listen to twice in a row.
The graveyard book by Neil Gaiman.
It's amazing and you will thank me.
There are a few different versions.
I like the version that Neil narrates himself,
one of the most soothing voices of all time.
The second book is vagabonding by Rolf Potts,
p,
O,
t t,
s which had a huge impact on my life and formed the basis for a lot of what
would later become the four hour workweek,
so go to audible.com forward slash Tim and you can choose one of these two books
or any of many,
many other options that could be books,
magazines,
and much more.
As a listener of the Tim Ferriss show,
you can also access a free 30 day trial.
Just go to audible.com forward slash to him.
You can't make more time,
but you can make the most of it,
so turn your travel or your commute into something more with a free trial at
audible.
Go to audible.com forward slash Tim to start now and get your free 30 day trial.
This podcast is brought to you by four sigmatic.
I reached out to these Finnish folks,
young entrepreneurs,
very talented.
After a acrobat introduced me to one of their products,
which is mushroom coffee.
This specific one includes Chaga and lion's mane and it knocked my socks off.
I highly recommend if you try it,
you start with half a packet.
It's very strong and lights you up like a Christmas tree in the best way
possible.
People are always asking me what I use for cognitive enhancement and for right
now this is the answer.
I try to force this on all of my house guests.
It is a hell of a thing.
If I have employees or people come over who are working on projects with me,
I always try to feed it to them because I'm going to get the limitless effect
and get a lot more out of them.
The first time I mentioned this product and four sigmatic on the podcast,
their products sold out in less than a week,
so you may want to check them out soon.
If you're listening to this and the coffee tastes like coffee,
it takes just seconds to prepare with hot water and oddly enough only includes
40 milligrams of caffeine,
so it has less than half of what you'd get in a regular cup of coffee.
I don't get any jitters.
Acid reflux or stomach burn,
any of that.
It's very unusual and very,
very cool.
So if you don't like caffeine,
they also offer very strong but caffeine free mushroom elixirs,
which I will sometimes have in the evening.
I find Chaga specifically to be very,
very grounding and earthy.
So that is another option and I have a cupboard full of their products at the
moment,
which is right around the corner of my kitchen.
You can try something.
You could try sample pack,
which is great.
Also right now by going to foursigmatic.com forward slash Tim,
that's foursigmatic,
f,
O,
u,
R s,
I,
g,
m,
a t I c.com forward slash Tim and use the code Tim t I m to get 20% off of your
first order and they're not that expensive anyway.
If you were in the experimental mindset,
I do not think you'll be disappointed to try map.